bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono dj ed oggi i ragazzi
prima di cominciare voleva soltanto per
una premessa
grazie infinite per che abbiamo
raggiunto il traguardo di 300 mila
iscritti grazie infinite veramente per
il traguardo che abbiamo raggiunto tutti
insieme ovviamente non solo io ma tutti
quanti e cochi ragazzi ne parleremo più
avanti oggi siamo sul re me io non
riesco a pronunciare più i nomi dei
videogiochi non so perché i mezzi in the
game praticamente ragazzi è un
videogioco e quando l'ho visto detto
bomba star devo assolutamente farlo
cazzo perché etico devo uffici lato non
si sa perché non chiedetemelo ospiti la
cometa favi sbarca sulla terra terrestri
sono cazzi vostri ragazzi perché c'è un
troll face perché c'è la foto di justin
bieber un ragazzino già ve lo dico
aspettatevi di tutto la sta roba perché
ci siamo appena suicidati è normale in
un gioco state tranquilli
fink inside out the box espresse space
to continue ok sono morto
aspettavo questo cazzo vai dove siamo
sono con leonardo di caprio e lui è
identico ragazzi in champ per chi non lo
sapesse inception e uno attratto dei
miei film preferiti e praticamente
nell'impostare da un sogno all'altro
come sto facendo io adesso prima che
devono passare sostanze che ruotano non
chiedetemi perché ruotano probabilmente
qualcuno si è fumato un cannone è bello
pesante qui ma non importa la andiamo
avanti qua madonna anzi ho mai mangiato
fagioli che c'è il turbo ma che cazzo fa
ragazzi è impossibile non ci posso non
so come cazzo faccia una persona andare
così veloce è bellissima
ed è così che ci si sveglia la mattina
mmmm jackson giusto diretto christoper
trolla braga ve l'avevo detto questo
gioco cioè aveva era strano red rain
bones the game
adesso devo sparare arcobaleni dal culo
fantastico mi mancava sta cosa ragazzi
c'è sempre stato il mio sogno segreto
quello di sparare arcobaleni dal culo
perché mi sono squartati in 10 mila
pezzi
ammettetelo raga che questo è il
superpotere che tutti vorrebbero avere
ditelo titolo che fantastico come cazzo
si pasta party impossibile ragazzi c'è
spider man che spara ragnatele se
superman che vola e io sparo io
ricoprendo alcuno si si si
non so come ho fatto ragazzi non me lo
chiedete andiamo avanti spariamo i
nostri arcobaleni tutto fatto a morire
e ciò poi a dallas pari al khobar india
il culo ma non sai alzare un braccio per
arrampicarti se ce l'ho fatta
ragazze cosa cazzo sta facendo sa che
c'è una bella botta sto tizio neanche
grossa squadra ma che cazzo di giorgio
sto giocando io non voglio leggi lady
gaga centrale di gaga lady gaga the game
fatta bellissima ragazza supermeet
questo dovrebbe essere colta che cazzo è
un riferimento a super meat boy con i
vestiti ma no io chi veramente non ho
idea di chi cazzo abbia fatto sto gioco
ma fare un remake di super meat boy con
lady gaga è la cosa più thread che
potessero fare fantastico datore di gare
è morta ci dispiace avete capito lady
gaga poi cd quindi è morta e ci dispiace
non fa ridere solamente penso che sto
gioco sia più difficile di super meat
boy tanto ragazzi volete che faccia
super meat boy come l'avete detto ma
cosa non lo so bene
madonna donna si è fatta ce l'ho fatta
ciò fatta ce l'ho fatta sì grande
ragazzi siamo oggi stiamo arrampicando
su dei telefoni non chiedetevi perché
non so come ma ce la sto facendo sto
sprecando tutto di sangue ma chi se ne
fotte
vai gaga facci vedere chi sei tutto il
resto andiamo avanti facebook the game
che cazzo di per cosa cosa mi devono far
fare su facebook cota comando zuckerberg
avrete questo è un po che io gli ho
sempre odiati sti cosi non mi servono un
cazzo vai così farmville regalo non si
ha esploso tutto ragazzi abbiamo
distrutto facebook ipad del claim questo
sono curiosi cos'è sono steve jobs
hanno fatto lost hanno fatto lost questo
gioco è fottutamente è tutto ragazzi che
cazzo perché cazzo c'è chi esce il loro
[Musica]
fair madonna ragazzi impazzita qualcuno
la fermi
ok perfetto ed ora il momento del boss
c'è il boss ragazzi sto gioco c'è il
boss comic book movie ruba a perfetto
sono gli occhiali 3d ed è fantastico e
devo battere rubate anno perché non devo
farmi schiacciare dai possano giusto
prima che questi così si diminuiscano
grande ho vinto il masters il gioco sta
nello negare un film da blockbuster una
cosa difficilissima ma non ci possiamo
fare ce la possiamo fare
ci sono c'è anche avatar fantastico e
import security che cazzo estero a
buongiorno lei a chuck norris col tasto
sinistro del mouse devo trascinare gli
oggetti dismessi devo svestire sto tizio
perché perdevo cliccare qui no io non
glieli le vostre cose devo veramente
andare avanti sono costretto scudate
perfetto c'è la cintura di castità al
massimo 80 per cento completo dove le
valli il lucchetto a notevole facciamo
levargli tutto perfetto ragazze privacy
mesiano ed air force ce l'ha piccolo
tanto lo stai tranquillo osama bin laden
c'è perché c'è bin laden che sta
sbattendo un beh con addosso un tizio
sto cercando io perché mi avete
consigliato sta roba cos'è fa vj non ha
messo un nuovo video cazzo perché c'è o
bin laden morto perché ci siamo i
soldati uccidono le persone
favi ti osserva molto attentamente
perché diamo manzoni giusto così siamo
ok siamo con justin bieber devono
premere il tasto giu hanno nove metri
ragazzi cosa cazzo stoffa c'è qualcuno
mi spiega perchè posso cantare con
justin bieber spegnimento ragazzi questo
è il richiamo delle ragazze cioè io devo
spostare la ragazza cantando ok grazie
anche guardiamo sale edwards io ho paura
di cosa può fare edward ho paura sono
contratti bieber e siamo da miley cyrus
non devo possiamo vendere ai ragazzi
devo vendere i ragazzi raga io non so
veramente più che cazzo dire visto gioco
perché sta succedendo di tutto terremoti
devo non cadere ok devo resistere
resistere il 30 secondi o ancora ok ok
ci sono ci sono ci sono ci sono youtube
dei game ragazzi ci mancava il nostro
cazzo dove sia no non il nostro caso il
nostro youtube dove cazzo siamo lo
farello galko soffusi a sto mandando
avanti indietro ma mio dio ma chi cazzo
ci sarebbe mai arrivato
sono per niente questo è il video lo sto
guardando fino alla fine
mettete mi piace sai che scritta ragazzi
mettete mi piace se perché c'è scritto
qui i ragazzi devo salire sui commenti
di youtube ma che cazzo di senso ha
quando davanti fino alla fine esploso
tutto ancora sto tizio basta ai box
credo di essere arrivato al boss finale
non ne sono sicuro però lato c'è una
faccia intelligentissima il tuo gioco
ragazzi dopo tutto sto casino io sono
curiosissimo di vedere chi cazzo è il
boss finale questa è la tizia di portare
due ragazzi che sia un bene ma non ne
sono convintissimo vabbè comunque noi
proviamo a vedere che cazzo succede
perché ho già visto di tutto finora c'è
il non mi stupirei pd niente sicuramente
tutto fatto c'è angry birds domanda lo
ha colpito lo ha colpito gioca adesso
sono quello con cui che spara gli
arcobaleni da culo ragazzi io ci provo
quando non so quanto riesco a faccia al
tenore un attimo si no lo faccio fatto
non lo veder cazzo ce l'ho fatta devo
colpito l'ho colpito io adesso siamo con
obama il cazzo el'ultimo trender né coi
capelli ragazzi l'unione fa la forza
incredibile
ragazzi siamo star con justin bieber di
nuovo si gioca la sto facendo in qualche
modo li sto facendo tutti ho colpito è
morto a devo togliere ma perché devo
deludere la gente sta roba
mi dispiace veramente denudarsi ma devo
farlo zio devo scoprire la tua identità
ski 6 fatti vedere
basti vedere fatti che schifo io non ho
ben capito chi cazzo alla sto tizio ma
ho paura adesso non vado più a dormire
cos'è la scritta bruttissima io ho paura
di massimo animo all'inizio sono
all'inizio mi suicido cometa fa vj
ragazzi
abbiamo visto che l'abbiamo guardate in
due non andare in buongiorno non e da lì
chi sia spazio ma l'abbiamo massacrato
di botte
ragazzi io non so che cosa cazzo appena
giocato c'era di tutto e se qualcuno di
voi ha capito una minima cosa di questo
gioco lo scriva nei commenti perché io
sinceramente non ci ho capito un emerito
cazzo di niente anche ragazzi svegli non
è piaciuto come al solito lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi video trovate la
descrizione ad essere per iscritti
iscrivetevi non ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video per ragazzi